[Musique]
bonjour à tous et bienvenue dans ce
nouveau numéro du 7-8 culture et tout de
suite le sommaire de ce mercredi 3 mai
un spectacle pour les petits comme pour
les grands d'arc circus c'est depuis ce
mardi au théâtre national de saint
quentin en yvelines
c'est un spectacle à découvrir en
famille l'ensemble continua mais tout
récent il été créé en 2007 à versailles
nous avons rencontré son directeur
artistique david shivers et le 4 juin le
vélodrome national de saint quentin en
yvelines accueille la deuxième édition
de mars et rites ce sera la nuit de
l'électro on débute avec un spectacle
adapté aux petits comme aux grands d'arc
circus c'est un spectacle créé en temps
réel par deux artistes un musicien et un
plasticien de touche à tout dont les
disciplines s'entremêlent une touche de
magie à partir d'une histoire originale
écrite par pète l'auteur du prince de
motordu regarder le dark circus est en
ville un cirque où chaque numéro est une
mise en péril un accident qu'on croirait
presque programmée
[Musique]
dark circus est créée en live par deux
magiciens romain brémond et jean
baptiste mallet une oeuvre à 90% en noir
et blanc
comment on passe de la tristesse à la
joie
si on n'a jamais été triste on sait pas
ce que c'est que de joyeux et donc voilà
il ya quelque chose qui est de cet ordre
là dans le rapport et puis après il ya
énormément de messages qu'on a qui sont
qui sont dedans c'est un conte donc il
ya plusieurs niveaux de lecture et c'est
pour ça que c'est des spectacles qui
s'adresse aussi à toutes et à tous selon
les âges des cultures des gens qui c'est
la première fois qu'il mettait bien en
interne comme des gens qui sont abonnés
à deux scènes nationales et des
prouesses techniques et artistiques
illustre au plus près une histoire
originale de pef l'auteur du célèbre
prince de motordu on a mis deux ans pour
créer ce spectacle c'est ce qu'on met
généralement pour créer un spectacle
assez notre 4e et
c'est long parce que on fait tout à 2 2
la composition des morceaux à la
construction des décors et des
marionnettes à la conception de dessin
et le comment on va amener l'histoire a
existé avec des systèmes d'animation
comme du sable décor déroulant comme on
a pu en voir au début du cinéma une
histoire noire qui ne manque pas
d'humour
une bulle poétique où les petits ces
merveilles et les grands crus deviennent
des enfants
on reste au théâtre national de saint
quentin en yvelines avec trissotin où
les femmes savantes macha makeïeff qui
est aussi la créatrice des deschiens
signe là une mise en scène pop et
acidulées du classique de molière
regarder
[Musique]
finalement aventure en lumière et
[Applaudissements]
musique à présent avec un concert celui
que donnera l'ensemble continuum le 5
mai prochain à versailles l'ensemble qui
est basée à la cité un royal a été créé
en 2016 son répertoire va du baroque au
moderne
son directeur david timbers est un
violoniste franco américain et nous
l'avons rencontré le sujet réalisé avec
mika linderhof et si lyon de vraiment
faire ce crescendo
david shiver ce violoniste professionnel
aime partager sa passion
chaque mardi depuis sept mois il donne
des cours de violon à l'école de musique
de buc le jongle un petit peu cette
année entre les entre les deux mais je
trouve quand même temps
les deux activités sont tout à fait
complémentaires c'est à dire que de
l'enseigné on apprend beaucoup en même
temps le fait de devoir expliquer ça
oblige à réfléchir à se poser des
questions et et c'est vrai que ça en
fait ça est dedans ça dans sa
progression en tant que musicien
ce soir-là il est deux apprentis
violoniste a méprisé vivaldi dans deux
jours ils ont un examen ils mettent
beaucoup ouvrent dans des bons conseils
ou en violant des conseils de technique
des conseils pour quand on est sur scène
ou pour le sont pour comment on les
choses ou le morceau plus facile à jouer
[Musique]
le musicien franco américains fondent en
2016 l'ensemble continuum à versailles
une dizaine d'artistes amoureux de la
musique baroque et moderne
c'était un projet que j'avais en tête
déjà depuis longtemps
auparavant j'étais plutôt dans la
musique
enfin dite moderne c'est à dire que je
jouer du violon sur sur instruments
modernes
j'ai pris goût et passion pour la
musique ancienne
j'ai découvert ça progressivement on va
dire depuis à 10 ans à peu près j'ai
travaillé beaucoup avec avec john eliot
gardiner pour cette saison culturelle et
sont en résidence à l'église notre dame
de la cité royale
ils seront en concert le 5 mai prochain
à barres après la gare saint lazare en
septembre la musique électro va investir
on avait le droit national de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines des artistes
dont un état octave one ou paranoid
london proposeront près 2 15 heures de
concert environ 5000 personnes sont
attendues quelques questions à bruce
goldstein chargé des communications du
vélodrome alors série c'est l'un des
plus fameux festival électro sur la
place parisienne à la base et donc ils
ont testé osé venir réaliser
l'expérience au concours national de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines et dix
artistes presque 15 heures de concert ce
soir
comment ça va se dérouler alors bref
vous l'avez dit en se pendant 15 heures
avec une série de tête d'affiche
successives on errant sur un modèle
classique en termes de festivals donc on
va accueillir un peu plus de de 4000
personnes voire 5000 à l'intérieur du
vélodrome nationale
sur le modèle des autres festivals qui
se réalise à l'international ce que
c'est aussi un festival a raison ce
international donc
donc voilà on rend très content de
réaliser l'expérience ici 50 ans et demi
je passais vous dans l'air centrale sert
à part circuler dans les gradins ouais
exclusivement à l'intérieur
donc on a pris soin de respecter le
cahier des charges qui nous a été
imposée par la mairie de montigny donc
exclusivement à l'intérieur du vélodrome
nationale et non pas intérieur extérieur
donc oui effectivement on aura une scène
centrale sur l'art centrale ici
jusqu'ici derrière moi avec un flux de
personnes qui circulera évidemment au
centre de l'aréna mais également en
tribune
une petite précision dans les annonces
interdit aux mineurs massé le sait la
loi qui veut ça aussi on va avoir de la
vente de certaines boissons alcoolisées
et puis par mesure de sécurité également
c est important de respecter le cahier
des charges qui se fait habituellement
est traditionnellement ce type de
manifestation donc effectivement
interdit aux mineurs on a ouvert la
billetterie à environ un mois même trois
semaines peut-être on a vendu 1000
places en 72 heures donc ça suit son
cours et on sera très certainement
complet avant avant l'échéance merci
merci à vous pour découvrir de jeunes
talents direction plaisir ce week end la
clé des champs propose une scène
tremplin clé en scène rendez vous le 6
mai à 20h45 pour supporter votre artiste
favori
nous partons maintenant aux
clayes-sous-bois l'artiste plasticien
louzoun nous emmène dans les profondeurs
de l'océan
on y découvre un monde malmené par les
activités de l'homme l'exposition
octopus men lumière son et recyclage
toutes ces oeuvres sont réalisées en
matériaux recyclés on écoute l'artiste
il était au micro de nicolas bendriss
j'aime bien le métal ouais le métal
parce que il est capricieux mais il
renvoie bien la lumière c'est que c'est
la matière guidé le métal il guide bien
quand je le travaille je suis pas
forcément maîtres de la matière elle
mène aussi vers son chemin et avec la
lumière ça marche vraiment bien
le coup de coeur cinéma de cette semaine
c'est celui d'aurélie sergent du grenier
à sel de trappes écouter le coup de
coeur du grenier à sel pour le mois de
mai se portent sur un film magnifique
c'est un film français qui fait
maintenant partie du patrimoine mondial
de l'unesco qui a été réalisé par le
grand marcel carné et l'immense poète
jacques prévert qui est un succès
fabuleux
dès sa sortie en salles au lendemain de
la seconde guerre mondiale en 1945 qui
est aussi porte à l'écran par des
acteurs très talentueux qui sont arletty
et jean louis barrault ce film est connu
aussi pour avoir montré les coulisses du
théâtre est mis en valeur l'art du
pantomime
vous l'aurez deviné il s'agit des
enfants du paradis
le film de marcel carné dans sa version
complète en deux actes d'une durée de 3
heures 10 bienvenue au cinéma le grenier
à sel
rendez vous le vendredi 12 mai à 20h45
attention c'est une séance unique bon
film bonne projection
[Musique]
et comme chaque semaine quelques rendez
vous à noter avant de nous quitter le
premier c'est de l'humour celui de nadia
roz elle est la révélation du marrakech
du rire 2015
son spectacle ça fait du bien vous
embarque dans un univers délirant
regardez cet extrait j'ai besoin de
personne pour faire la fête dans ma tête
ajoute madame bonjour
voilà pour les tests mère tu sors toi tu
ne gardes encore je sors tout vendeur
mutuelle
ouais c'est la mode toi c'est hyper
pratique pour décapsuler les biarrots là
où c'est relou c'est dans le métro faut
pas être trop près de la ville sainte et
ventouses talent et à gages qui tu as
gagné
la voiture s'est vu le concept c'est
quand tu essayes de faire entrer yolande
moreau d'andré totaux ya conflit elikia
et joseph sont deux enfants soldats qui
fut un camp rebelle
ils trouveront refuge pardon auprès
d'une infirmière qui deviendra plus tard
le bruit des os qui craquent et à
découvrir à la ferme de bel ébat ce
vendredi regarder elle écrivait dans un
cahier pour s'assurer qu'elle n'oublie
rien et pour dire ce qu'elle n'osait pas
dire à voix haute
elle disait que les mots de la bouche ne
peuvent pas tout raconter ils sont trop
près de la haine et de la vengeance
tu retrouves une en bas il faut marcher
je connais pas le chemin avec les
rebelles ont malgré des joutes nuls et
les armes arrivent au menton aujourd'hui
la rivière je pense qu'on peut y arriver
le cette culture est maintenant terminée
je vous remercie de nous avoir suivi on
se retrouve mardi prochain
[Musique]